now something looks like it's going
horribly wrong because what I was
setting out to find was the equation of
a chord right but unless I'm mistaken
what we found is the equation of the
tangent do you see they're exactly the
same equation I've just changed notes
into ones or two so that kind of thing
it's the same equation there's something
going wrong well let's think about this
wake up
I hate iOS 11 for all the things I love
about it I hate my inability to aim my
finger this is like there we go let me
make that a little there we go so here's
my um here's my parabola can you see it
there's my quarter contact it's in black
do you notice it there and this is
something your book can't do as you move
your point around you just get different
tangents which give you a different
chord of contact is that okay so make
sense all right now here's what I want
you to notice okay what happens if I
play around a little bit and like I want
you to look at your your neighbors
quarter contact okay I want you to look
at the corner contact and I also want
you to compare it to where their
external point is okay like I all I ask
you all of a pick a different external
point some of you have probably picked
an external point quite far for your
parabola and some of you pick one that
is quite close okay I wonder if you
notice any differences between them
watch what happens when I take this guy
which is quite far away and I'm going to
bring it closer to the parabola now
watch carefully as I take this external
point and I bring it in see my blue and
my orange tangents do you see them do
you notice that they're sort of getting
closer and closer together
now hold on think about that for a
second why are they getting closer and
closer together
hmm well if your external point is
closer to the parabola then the other
points are in contact with are also
getting closer if the points are getting
closer their tangents will become more
alike does that make sense what happens
if I keep going what happens if I don't
just make it closer but if I actually
take that external point and make it
let's see how accurate I can be and
internal points oh I missed I told you
it would be hard
let's try again there we go ah easy to
imagine I'm happy with that that'll have
to do ok now what's going on what's
happening why are these equations
equations of tangents crazy the tangents
and equations are quite like you usually
think of those is quite different
objects but thankfully we're pretty well
equipped to figure out what happens when
objects you think of is quite different
become the same object
do you remember write this guy down for
me mm-hmm do you remember
just be careful note what I've written
in what I haven't written what is that
this is a gradient right what's at the
gradient of right now right now it's the
gradient of a seeker right because look
here's a spot and here's another spot
where there's rice here is there's run
on the denominator right so this is
actually this yeah does that make sense
and then the x's cancel okay
currently it's the gradient of a secant
how do I turn it into the great need of
a tangent okay now it's a tangent now
it's a tangent okay now if we come back
to all of this business right
we actually are dealt with chords before
we're just not dealt with these wiener
looking chords okay does anyone remember
what is the equation of the chord it's
not on the reference sheet so you need
to know this one it starts with 1/2 very
good mm-hmm
there's something here first
someone helping out that's it that's
this is the yeah okay good - a PQ yeah
okay now remember I told you as you move
your external point closer and closer
and closer your tangents get more and
more alike in other words these two
things get closer and closer together
so in fact this tangent turns into a
chord right or vice versa actually but
this is the chord sorry turns into the
tangent okay and that's exactly what we
observed I'm not even going to pull down
the screen anymore because I'm lazy
that's exactly what we observed here
okay as you're tangent tangent to get
closer and closer together they ceased
to become two different objects and then
they're just that was a good one then
they're just a tangent okay so on the
reference sheet you will find two
formulas one for the equation of a
tangent and then the other one for the
equation of the court of contact this is
one that's on the reference sheet and
did the same
formula because they're the same object
the difference is just a limit okay